[Music]
let's go to laura in portland oregon hey
laura what's going on
well i was fired on friday i'm
sorry yeah
actually i'm looking forward to it being
the best thing that ever happened to me
i love it what happened
well there was a new manager that came
in in january and
she cleaned house pretty much put
everyone that had been there before her
you know on terrible mindless menial
tasks etc and i i was next my hair was
on the chopping block on friday so i am
57 years old i have finally grown out my
full gray white hair so i look like
santa claus
and now i'm i'm up for looking for
another job and my biggest concern
is that i had a great professional
career
all you know after college etc and i had
a horrible divorce that i went through
and
long story short my
job um history had some gaps in it and
this company i worked for for seven
years they're basically my only
reference that i can use and they fired
me so now i'm like i've got no
confidence my faith is a little bit
shaky
and i have outdated skills so
um i've got the financial loss the
stress um i was trying to get debt free
and yeah so any advice would be helpful
yeah that's a lot so
do me a favor can you just inhale real
deep and hold your breath for a second
take a big deep breath
and just hold it three
two now let it out
can we just all say
this sucks i'm sorry
it does yeah it's it's a lot
um our my friend coleman we were talking
about some research the other day that
losing a job
is can be as devastating psychologically
as losing a loved one
yeah and you put on top of that
you're
still
wrestling with the divorce how long ago
was that
uh that was 2006. okay so that's that's
still fresh in your soul there though
pretty much yeah it was 2013 i had a
nervous breakdown basically and
got back into life after that so yeah so
this is your first big stress test since
the last nervous breakdown of the things
you learned about yourself and some
tools right and here we are
and
yes you're driving down the highway and
the car's starting to rattle on you a
little bit and you remember this your
body remembers this
so
what were you doing what was your job
um i was working on a government
contract doing scanning of um
department of human services files like
child abuse cases adoptions etc so i
would prep all those files removing
staples paperclips etc sure put them
into the scanner and then scan them
index it export it to see it etc so what
is this nonsense about you have outdated
skills you can't call our show and not
tell us the truth you know what you're
doing you can do cool stuff
well i used to in my previous life i was
a trade show manager for a high tech
company and did trade shows all over the
world basically okay hold on hold on
hold on hold on laura you've told me two
different things
and i wanna
can i call you out a little bit even
though we're in front of a couple of
dozens you're welcome billion people
you've told me about your
past job about who you used to be yeah
about your past marriage who used to be
yes and i wanted to put a period at the
end of those sentences
because we have to deal with today
and just because you used to run trade
shows and then you went to preparing
documents for
child abuse cases and
adoptions
there is no difference in importance you
may have made more money than one and
one may have been flashier
but both jobs are necessary
and the next job you get is going to be
necessary
and just because some guy walked out on
you
and said something else is better than
laura who's my new friend by the way
is reflective of his actions not yours
yeah
one of the demons
one of the hallmarks of depression is we
keep trying to pull the past
back into the present with us
and we we want to say this is the way
it's always been this is the way it's
always going to be i'm going to do
something else i'm going to get involved
in another job another relationship and
that's going to leave me too
and i want to shift that narrative and
say
man we got a new manager
phooey
next
right yes
i'm freaking laura with long awesome
gray hair and i'm 57.
i can do anything i want to
so here's the question not
how do i get back to what was because
that's gone the question is what do i do
next so what do you do next what do you
want to do laura you're 57 you're almost
halfway i can see you living to be 115.
so you're about halfway what do you want
to do
well ideally i would like to find a job
that pays my bill well enough that i can
foster a puppy for a local organization
that gives service dogs to our veterans
with ptsd
i think you can make it i just need to
support myself so you just want to
afford a puppy
yeah i want to foster a puppy for a
veteran but what do you want to do with
like work like your life
um i would like to get back into high
tech
or
work in a marketing department probably
not as the lead marketing person that
goes out to see customers but
more behind the scenes with the
marketing support um
preferably for a high-tech company or a
um
like a chemical engineering company so
do you know anybody who works in high
tech or in kim and kim that you could go
sit down and have coffee with
i do know a couple people in high tech
good then today
and tomorrow
you are promising us say i promise
i promise that you're going to reach out
to those people
directly and say hey can we do coffee
and then you're going to say management
restructured and here i am and i want in
y'all's building how do i get in
and i will make copies i can prepare
documents or i can run the whole show
like i've done
i can do it all i don't know a lot about
high tech i'm 57 i've got gray hair
they can just get over it because i'm
coming full laura
exactly okay so here's what i want you
to do two things two important things
number one
i want you to every time the past comes
up
i want you to take a deep breath
and exhale and say
thank god it's today
and you're gonna you may do that a
thousand times in your first day and a
thousand times in the second day third
day fourth day we're gonna turn your
dial not from the past but to today and
we're gonna begin looking forward
the second thing is is george asked a
great ques like what do you want to do
you want to go work for a high-tech
company that's fantastic i'm going to
reach out and start making some of those
connections like our friend the
proximity prince i got to get in i got
to get in the door and i know some
people in those areas um real real quick
we're up against the clock
you got enough money to pay bills for a
couple of weeks
for a couple of months where are
about about a month and a half okay you
may need you may need laura to run down
and get a job at a coffee shop
to pay bills and there's no shame in
that game you may need to run down to a
local um whatever and they are hiring
like crazy and find a job that's going
to pay you bills while you
bridge the gap between where you are now
and where you're going to end up
and you can get yourself that puppy stay
on the line we're going to give you a
copy of our friend ken coleman's brand
new book from paycheck to purpose walk
into the seven steps to get the career
you love and by the way
it doesn't matter if you're 27 or 57
it's not too late it's not too late and
hey we'll go ahead and get you a copy of
his assessment so you can walk through
and say once i get into this big tech
big kim what do i actually want to do
that would be fantastic right
man george that's big time
she's spirited laura's a stunt she's
going to make it happen make it happen
that's one hour
i just want to make sure we go to that
foster puppy john we'll get we'll get
that foster puppy just not a french
bulldog